selon andré glucksmann
m
bonsoir andrey vous connaissez françois
berléand jane soirée ryan et julien
lepers
bonsoir et merci de m'accueillir
mais vous êtes le bienvenu comme
d'habitude
alors andré glucksmann vous avez publié
en 1967
votre premier livre qui s'appelait le
discours de la guerre et aujourd'hui
vous publié le discours de la haine
qu'est ce qui a changé que la haine est
devenu sans limite si vous voulez dans
la guerre il ya de la haine c'est vrai
il faut pas se faire d'illusions j'avais
écrit mon bouquin sur la guerre au
vietnam y avait de la haine des deux
côtés et pas mal sauf que les
vietnamiens communiste qui terrorisait
leur population sans problème n'ont
jamais eu l'idée de faire sauter new
york
ouais hein c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la haine et sans frontières sans
frontières géographiques sans frontières
morales évidemment et même sans
frontières géopolitiques si vous voulez
la bombe atomique pakistanaise
le docteur anne qu'il a fait et trafic
avec la corée du nord serait pas
vraiment islamique les trafics avec
l'iran qui est chiite
il trafiquait jadis avec le brésil et
l'argentine quand c'était des pays
fasciste et cetera et cetera
ouais ce que voulait dire c'est qu'en
depuis le 11 septembre fait le le
monopole de la dévastation est entre
toutes les mains
finalement ben oui si vous voulez on est
passé de la bombe h ou le monopole de la
dévastation c'était entre cette
puissance nucléaire à peu près à la
bombe humaine et alors là il ya plus de
monopole c'est à la portée vraiment tout
le monde ceux qui font sauter le
pentagone ce qui est arrivé avec un
canif et une bande de copains pour le
prix d'un appartement d'une pièce à new
york ou à paris 1
c'est vraiment à la portée de n'importe
qui oui c'est plus la prolifération de
l'armé nucléaire
c'est la prolifération de la haine à oui
elle est vraiment de la haine parce
qu'on tue absolument n'importe qui si
vous voulez imaginez que vous soyez un
banlieusard à madrid et que vous soyez
prêt dans l' attaque de
d'atocha ont bien un quelqu'un qui
nettoie les escaliers dans les twin
towers et que vous soyez là ce jour là
imaginez que vous puissiez poser la
question aux gars qui arrive avec son
avion et qui se fait péter et vous lui
dites pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui peut répondre il pourra
répondre ici il n'ya pas pourquoi c'est
la réponse du ss à primo levi quand il
était lui déportés dit raphaël var où
mme virk heimbach on voit là et ça c'est
si vous voulez ya d'une part une
puissance de dévastation qui est
terrifiante parce qu'elle est
équivalente à hiroshima si on fait
sauter des tours de new york on peut
faire sauter une centrale nucléaire on
peut faire un tchernobyl délibéré et
puis quand on prend des enfants en otage
et qu'on en retire dedans on est capable
de tout alors ça c'est le deuxième
aspect la dévastation la technique de
dévastation mais aussi la volonté de
dévaster la volonté de tuer n'importe
qui on est en face de ça aujourd'hui
parmi toutes les haines qui prolifèrent
à la surface de la terre et dieu sait
s'il en a la preuve je comprends pas
pourquoi vous en choisissez 3 enfin
c'est à dire que vous avez tort d
choisir mais nous on choisit c'est que
trois choisis c'est la haine des juifs
la haine des américains et la haine des
femmes pourquoi ces trois là parce que
c'est les plus mondial c'est parce que
aujourd'hui il ya plus de marxisme de
ces terrains il n'y a pas d'idéologie
mondiale par contre il faut quand même
pour la haine des américains ça veut pas
dire que les américains se trompent pas
et qu'on n'ait pas le droit de les
critiquer la haine c'est pas critiquer
ce que fait quelqu'un parce que ça c'est
normal on peut être hostile et critiquer
mais ces critiques et ce quelqu'un si
vous voulez le juif il est haï par
l'antisémite parce qu'il est né juif ou
le tutsi au rwanda c'est parce qu'il
était né tutti qu'il devait être exécuté
et ça a été le dernier génocide du
siècle ça a été un million de personnes
en trois mois c'est à dire dix mille
personnes
coupés à la machette et à la
mitraillette par jour
alors haïr quelqu'un c'est haïr ce qu'il
est et n'avait pas à dire ce qu'il fait
parce que ça c'est on peut être aussi là
ce que fait quelqu'un alors quand les
américains me demander quand il ya eu
manhattan
ouais les trois quarts du monde ont
trouvé que c'était tout à fait
compréhensible que c'était bien fait
pour eux et c'est qu'ils avaient des
têtes ils ont pas danser parce qu'on est
quand même décembre et enfin eu et on
est partout dans le monde en europe en
chine partout pas seulement dans les
pays musulmans comme on dit et ça c'est
à dire les américains parce qu'ils sont
américains non pas parce qu'ils font des
mauvais choix les juifs c'est un peu
pareil et sartre a dit l'antisémite il
connaît pas le juif hitler il
connaissait pas les juifs vous voyez des
types avec des drôles de costumes bon
c'est tout mais il connaissait pas
iceman qui était le chef du massacre il
ne connaissait rien il faisait semblant
de connaître parce que ses acolytes est
encore plus ignorants cuit mais ils
connaissaient rien le l'antisémite des
saars il a aucun rapport aux juifs il
faut découpler il ans il s'en veut à lui
même il voudrait être parfait et idées
ben je suis pas parfait je sui fra j'ai
suivi le nez ram c'est la faute à osef
vous vous parle effectivement de la nuit
vous dit qu'aujourd'hui une
diabolisation par exemple de sharon
sharon égale hitler bouzid que
finalement on en arrive à travers ça à
une remise en cause de l'état d'israël
parce que finalement mais pourquoi
pourquoi hitler serait le patron d'un
état au moyen-orient au moyen orient ou
ailleurs voici ci est normalement
l'émanation d'un état qu'il a été lui et
ses bas on dit il faut supprimer c'est à
quelque chose de fou vous trouvez que
les médias occidentaux ont beaucoup
d'indulgence pour le terrorisme
palestinien presse est le seul non mais
attendez moi il ya une question que je
me suis posée mais j'ai vraiment mis du
temps à me poser j'ai pas compris le
terrorisme des irlandais l'irs a
condamné par tout le monde le terrorisme
des basses condamné par tout le monde
le terrorisme ou simplement la résist
on s'est remis des tchétchènes condamné
par tout le monde ça beau être une
guerre coloniale menée par deux puis
trois sans en parler aux pas question
y'a qu'un terroriste et j'appelle
terrorisme l'attaqué délibérée de gens
sans défense par des gens armés
je dis bien délibéré intentionnel il ya
qu un terrorisme dans ces dix dernières
années qui a été excusé expliqué avec
plus ou moins de complaisance ou bien
héroïsé par d'autres c'est le terrorisme
des palestiniens je me suis dit bon
c'est peut-être parce qu'ils sont
musulmans mais non les jets sont
musulmans si oui mais pourquoi alors
attendez andrey pourquoi il ya une
unicité de la cause palestinienne comme
on a parlé d'unicité de la shoah
pourquoi les palestiniens
pourquoi il échappe à la condamnation
universelle un oui c'est ça le problème
et on la seule explication c'est leur
cible et les traits particuliers assez
des juifs
c'est pour ça que je pense que si on
excuse seulement 1,1 terrorisme c'est
parce que sa cible bas elne excuses en
quelque sorte dans la troisième m dont
qui a la haine des juifs la haine de
l'amérique ce la haine des femmes
ah oui alors sa propre pourquoi les
femmes beaucoup écouté d'abord c'est un
petit cocktail qui a été fabriqué ou
plutôt réveillé par caen min quand il ya
eu la révolution islamique
la première chose qu'il a fait s'est
imposé le voile est toutes les femmes et
les premières manifestations contre
khomeiny alors que tout le monde les
intellectuels de gauche les
intellectuels de droite iranien
toussaint les ied et guerrien les
anciens marxisme léninisme communiste
tout ce qu'on veut les postes
historiques
tous étaient pour khomeiny il ya eu une
manifestation la première c'était une
manifestation de femmes qui ne voulait
pas porter le voile qui ne voulait
surtout pas être obligé porter le voile
que celle qu'il porte à porte
il y en avait mais pas être obligé et ça
apparemment en france on a dit mais
enfin il est fou ce vieux ce vieux
schnock et bien pas du tout ça a été une
idée géniale en algérie moi j'ai
j étais à l'époque pendant 10 ans on
égorgeait les filles ont les tuer parce
qu'elle ne voulait pas porter le voile
pareil en iran évidemment pareil en
afghanistan etc etc
le voile c'est un uniforme et alors je
me suis demandé pourquoi et j'ai
retrouvé d'autre façon de vouloir que la
femme soit [ __ ] et se mouiller et ce
comme le dit un très beau mouvement
contre ça mais put est soumis ça veut
dire pour les voeux à notre disposition
un tout en les considérant comme moins
que rien mais alors c'est quoi le
problème
bah c'est le même problème que sartre
note pour l'antisémite ce qu'on veut pas
voir chez l'autre qu'on déteste qu'on
est
c'est un miroir de notre propre
fragilité si vous voulez la femme et
c'est le risque de se tromper de la
tromper qu'elle nous trompent
bref c'est la fragilité des rapports
sains c'est aussi le chat la peinture
bleue moi quoi et oui on veut être dieu
le mal le super mal et est alors la
femme elle nous inquiète elle nous
perturbe
on casse le miroir andré voilà c'est
terrible autre bouquin parce que c'est
c'est une description du du monde
d'aujourd'hui qui est absolument
insoutenable par moments qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais il faut d'abord appeler
un chat un chat pas justifier la haine
une bombe une bombe humaine c'est
dégueulasse un point c'est tout alors
pour bon pour eux pour prendre l'exemple
ni israël palestine mais je crois que là
il ya aussi l'aspect de lutter contre la
haine qu'on porte en soi si vous voulez
quand un israélien décide de négocier et
risque de fait de se faire tuer par son
propre camp c'est ce qui est arrivé à
vis d'eux mêmes pour les palestiniens il
ya toujours des plus excités qui vous
liquide et là je crois que c'est de la
responsabilité de 2 chaque camp que de
lutter contre la haine qu'il porte en
lui mais en plus alors c'est aussi de
notre responsabilité je vous donne un
dernier exemple ne va pas me
faciliter mes rapports avec le
gouvernement mais je m'en fous je suis
vu je n'ai pas d'ambition ça l'arrivée
c'est bon puis c'est une vieille
histoire
mais voilà on reçoit yasser arafat
on le soigne c'est bien un nos médecins
doivent soigner tout le monde hein c'est
pas un jugement politique il ya un homme
malade reçoit immer et puis il ya une
rumeur qui se répand
il a été empoisonné et la rumeur elle
est terrible parce qu'elle nourrit la n1
la haine des plus excités contre les
modérés alors il paie et aussi la haine
contre sharon qui empoisonnent affamant
donc ça ça aide pas la paix 1 qu'est ce
que fait le gouvernement il dit rien il
dit rien il dit les dossiers médicaux
appartiennent à la famille moi je peux
pas les publier
et c'est vrai c'est la déontologie mais
il aurait pu dire autre chose et ça elle
n'a pas dit et il aurait dû le dire en
cinq colonnes à la une il aurait dû dire
un médecin français ne peut pas donner
le dossier médical de la malade mais un
médecin français est contraint s'il ya
le moindre soupçon de mort pas naturel
et donc l'empoisonnement 2-1 avertir la
justice et deux probablement procéder à
une autopsie et 3 de ne pas donner de
certificats d'inhumer si les médecins
français ont donné le certificat
d'inhumer en avait le droit allemand qui
gérait sans le découper c'est qu'ils ont
pensé qu'il n'y avait strictement pas
d'empoisonnement ni de soupçons
d'empoisonnement
mais il aurait dit ça le gouvernement
français aurait dit ça en gros et en
fort et bien ça aurait quand même
rabaisser la rumeur je sais bien que
pour napoléon on est encore à se
demander s'il aurait donné mais c'est
pas aussi fort qu'une rumeur et risque
des carnets et de chauffer à blanc des
gens qui n'ont pas besoin d'être chauffé
à blanc alors si vous voulez savoir
comment va mourir on mourra de la haine
des autres et de notre propre
inattention